a writer in ohio who captured the mood
of 2016 with a viral poem has a believe
it or not new outlook
in 2020. maggie smith's poem good bones
was about a parent
wrestling with what to tell her children
about a not so hot world
it was widely shared by people looking
for solace during and
after the contentious election of 2016.
well after connecting with so many
americans during that time
she's hoping to do it again with a new
book it's called keep moving and we
spoke we spoke
with maggie about how she's feeling this
time around
the world is at least 50 percent
terrible
and that's a conservative estimate that
was maggie smith in 2016.
and today as she looks back at the
admittedly dark
but also darkly funny work she published
four years ago
and for every kind stranger there is one
who would break you
though i keep this from my children
she'll be the first to admit she has not
always been inclined
to look on the bright side i call myself
a recovering pessimist
if we expect the worst we won't be
surprised
and in fact we'll be right it wasn't
made another ugly election fight first
of all hillary
everything's broken about it everything
and right after a gunman mowed down more
than 49 people in orlando
when her poem good bones happened to
appear in a small literary journal
a year after she'd written it i was just
writing it as
a mother raising two small kids in the
21st century
not quite sure how to explain
this world to them because i don't even
know how to really explain it to myself
but the work was soon everywhere on
social media
fueled by newspaper headlines and
celebrated by public radio international
which declared it poem of the year
in what some considered the worst year
ever
a complicated honor for its author i
call
it a disaster barometer when it's shared
widely
um it's because people need it and if
people need it
probably something has happened and a
lot has happened since then
with the poem booming online through
news cycles of violence and cruelty
and far too few moments of grace but
against the odds maggie smith herself
says she is no longer a pessimist
a transformation she credits to the
writing of her new book
trust that the present moment however
difficult
however different from what you'd
imagined has something to teach you
keep moving keep moving notes on loss
creativity and change is published by
simon
schuster a division of vicom cbs
it's not a work of poetry but a series
of little pep talks meant to focus
attention on what's possible
instead of what's lost i wrote this book
really
out of the desire to get myself from
point a to point b
smith's marriage was ending in 2018 and
she started writing
and then tweeting as a way to navigate
through the pain
accept that you are a work in progress
both
a revision and a draft you are better
and more complete than earlier versions
of yourself
but you also have work to do be open to
change
but as with good bones it turned out
that what maggie smith was trying to say
a lot of other people were looking to
hear people would say things like
this is exactly what i needed today or
they would joke
and say are you on my group text
it's about not looking in the rear-view
mirror and really focusing on the
present
and the possibility and potential of
what's
ahead and i don't know about you but i
need that more than ever
this year i think we all do to that end
the book is filled with both
hope and advice for making that hope a
reality
every person you encounter has a
struggle
a hidden wound something they carry that
hurts them
be kind maybe something you do
or say today could be the good medicine
they need
all of it quite a change for this
pessimist
in recovery self-help is a term uh i'm
curious
are you a self-help author now
i suppose i am i mean i say this book is
literal self-help
because i wrote it to help myself and
the fact that it might help
other people in 2020 and beyond
is is pretty magical and wonderful but
it's it's already done its work
for me yeah it's done it's worked for a
lot of other people as well
i asked her about being a self-help
author because i don't really consider
myself a self-help reader either but i
read that book and i responded to it and
i think a lot of other people
will as well i want it already i think
she's in my head not just when they said
group chat
yeah so many things that she said
resonated so deeply yeah keep moving
part especially
yeah it's going to be very hard to top
the success of good bones which
continues to be one of the most shared
poems
every year and every time something bad
happens she calls it a disaster
barometer
however these little nibbles of wisdom
that are in the new book
they really are yeah sustenance in fact
the reason i did the piece is because i
was in my kitchen with a friend who lost
their job during the pandemic
and the book had arrived in the mail
yeah for consideration and i was reading
some of the
the remarks to him and he responded and
i'm interested and you thought there's
something here there's something here
it was a man too yeah he needed to hear
it and other people do too i really love
that it started as a
as a self-help book for herself i mean
that's so
that's such an interesting way of
thinking about it and i was not familiar
with good bone did you know good bones
anthony i was not no i didn't
i didn't i wasn't aware of it oh wow you
got to find it no
i will it's devastating it is very hard
it's very hard to convey it
in a short segment it's worth a read
take a few minutes of your time